joining me now is Wisconsin Congressman
Mike Gallagher who will chair the select
committee on China and the new Congress
Congressman it's great to see you
tonight you know we know you're going to
be focused on these issues that we
raised in the angle but can you promise
us tonight that the GOP leadership is
not going to try to sell us again on
this trans-pacific partnership that you
heard Bob Lighthouse or the world expert
on trade agreements absolutely say
should be a non-starter
I've heard absolutely no discussion of
it in Congress I can't imagine it's
going to be a priority in fact if we're
interested in doing anything on trade I
actually think there's some low-hanging
fruit foremost among them would be a
free trade agreement with Taiwan itself
which is mired in a disagreement right
now if we want to pursue a trade
agreement a bilateral Trade Agreement
like that would make far more sense as
well as a post-brexit gold standard
trade agreement with the UK which is
completely Fallen by the wayside if we
want to draw closer economically and
technologically with our allies let's
think about how we can share
intermediate range missile technology
with the Aussies for example now that
we're no longer bound by the INF treaty
because Trump smartly got out of it so
we need to be thinking about how we
selectively decouple technologically
economically financially and in terms of
data in dollars from China potentially
removing permanent normal trade
relations from China not allowing them
to game the global trading system
oh that's that's music to the uh viewers
of the angle uh their ears because it's
been a complete loser for the American
middle class now as you heard in the
angle uh Congressman Congress secretary
Gina raimondo is refusing to say that we
should decouple from China what you just
referenced but given the fact that our
you know our so-called allies won't even
entertain the discussion of getting
tough on China shouldn't we begin to do
this ourselves given everything that
we've seen they cheat Us blind on trade
and obviously they're a slave state
well there's three urgent things I think
we need to do the first to ensure that
U.S technology is not going into China's
military modernization or abetting
China's genocide right now the second
thing is to cut off the flow of U.S
dollars to the same thing military
modernization genocide in particular tax
advantaged entities tax exempt and
entities think higher education
University endowments should not be
allowed to invest in China these are the
same people that are lecturing us about
ESG investing well China stinks at the E
the S and the G and if the G stands for
anything it should stand for genocide
and then finally we need to decouple in
terms of data this starts with Tick Tock
it is long past time we banned Tick Tock
we don't have a reciprocal data
arrangement with China and they
effectively control this uh this app and
the algorithms are highly addictive
highly deadly and they allow the Chinese
Communist party to effectively
selectively edit the news we do not want
the CCP e to control the largest Media
company in in America
Congressman why is a communist country
allowed to buy U.S real estate U.S major
agricultural companies food companies in
large tracks of of real estate near
military bases why is that allowed
this is an issue we absolutely need to
look into on the select committee on
China it shouldn't be allowed
particularly if there's a clear
affiliation with the pla or the Chinese
Communist Party the short answer is
because they hide these connections
sometimes through opaque arrangements
and oftentimes people don't understand
that at least since the passage of the
2017 National Security Law in China
there's really no thing such thing as a
private company in China everyone's
controlled by the CCP subjected to the
direction of the CCP and so it's
important that we understand who we're
dealing with this is a genocidal
Communist Regime that not only wants to
oppress their own citizens succeed where
the Soviet Union failed in perfecting
the the model of total party control but
increasingly to export that model around
the world they talk openly about
destroying the capitalist system led by
the United States in order to make way
for the Triumph of world socialism with
Chinese characteristics and slowly
they've turned us into a nation of
addicts addicted to cheap Chinese good
words addicted to Fentanyl and addicted
to the CCP control algorithms
and we're like let's buy more let's let
them buy more real estate Congressman
hey we're really looking forward to your
leadership on this committee we really
appreciate you joining us tonight have a
Merry Christmas
[Music]
and current American leadership isn't
just sabotaging the country abroad but
within as well the mainstreaming of pot
has come at the same time as the drug
has increased exponentially in its
potency it's THC levels as one highly
cited paper points out the consumption
of marijuana is associated with an
increase in violent behavior and a high
risk of psychosis for frequent users
but these issues they're a lot of
concern to those looking to cash in on
this burgeoning business documents
obtained by the LA Times show that
cannabis companies and investors
provided some of the early financial
support for UCLA's cannabis research
initiative they funded it writing checks
for tens of thousands of dollars in
donations and assisting with fundraising
events and they aren't alone Harvard MIT
UC San Diego are among the schools that
have accepted multi-million dollar gifts
in recent years joining me now is Luke
niferatos Executive Vice President of
smart approaches to marijuana Luke so
the research for how safe and great
wheat is some of the dollars are coming
from the weed Lobby are we getting that
right
yeah Laura thanks for having me on I got
to tell you big marijuana is terrified
right now because there are now volumes
of research telling us that this new
supercharged marijuana that the industry
is pumping out is causing psychosis
schizophrenia we're seeing addiction
rates go up they're targeting our kids
all kinds of car crashes on the roads so
all this is coming out in the research
so what do they do they go to their big
brother tobacco who by the way is their
biggest investor and they start pumping
out fake bogus research I'm telling you
right now one of the people that funded
the millions of dollars for UCLA's
research on marijuana that company was
called nugs okay it's not run by sarazic
Newton all right these are the can of
bros running these companies and they're
not trying to advance scientific
research they are paying for publicity
and misinformation which is exactly what
big tobacco did they killed millions of
Americans to make a buck and that's
exactly what marijuana wants to do along
with their big tobacco investors
now I mean this is corrupt to the core
and when you when you chat with folks
who don't you know maybe don't read up
on this or haven't really followed what
what it does especially to the young
brain with frequent use
they said well it's better for you than
alcohol and it has it relaxes you all
the medicinal benefits and to that you
say
well when I hear about the alcohol thing
I say well you know if you have a car
and you just broke your headlight do you
say okay well to be consistent let me
Smash in my tail light too I mean we
have issues with alcohol more than a
hundred thousand Americans die every
year related to alcohol right now so
it's not like that's going great and you
look at marijuana you have the industry
out there peddling these lies you know
marijuana helps with anxiety well we
have 10 research studies that just came
out in the last five years that tell you
marijuana actually makes anxiety worse
you know you hear these claims that oh
you know marijuana is not addictive yet
now the data are telling us from our
nation's highest and most revered
researchers that one in three people who
use marijuana in the last year now will
develop a cannabis use disorder that's
the medical diagnosis for addiction so
there's all these myths out there Laura
that the industry is trying to undermine
we got to get real science out there not
bogus science that's funded by industry
this reminds me a lot of the coveted you
know funding of research studies with
covet it reminds me a lot of that Luke
thank you for the work that smart
approaches to marijuana does on this
issue day in and day out we really
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else